ORS the ancient giant was Joy boy this
is one of the most popular and crazy
sounding one-piece theories in existence
so I sat down for the last 48 hours
straight and gathered all the evidence
that I could find on the internet to see
if it's plausible or not and I ended up
going down a rabbit hole so deep that it
made me question everything that I
thought I had known about one piece
especially with recent events in the
manga here's what I found starting with
what we know for a fact about the
mysterious figure Joy boy and the even
more mysterious race of Ancient Giants
in one piece we do know that joyboy
lived about 800 years ago around the
time of the Void Century we know that he
had a promise with Fishman Island that
he would raise the Noah with the help of
Poseidon but for an unknown reason that
promise was broken we also know that the
giant elephant's Anisha was also a
companion of Joy Boys and at some point
Joy boy left an unimaginable treasure
behind at the end of the grand line a
treasure now no known as the one piece
and Joy by also explained on the pony
glyphs that he would return in 800 years
time enter Luffy who upon unlocking gear
fifth for the very first time against
kaido was proclaimed by zonesia to be
the second coming of joyboy but wait if
we're talking about oars being Joy boy
some of you probably are already
thinking about a potential problem here
if we look back to Thriller bark it
stated that ORS died around 500 years
ago after all maurya found him Frozen in
the land of ice
um no mathematician clearly but 800 and
500 are two very different numbers so
doesn't that throw a little bit of a
wrench into this entire Theory already
well not really and there are two
reasons for this first as we'll discuss
in more detail in just a second there
are actually not one but two candidates
for Luffy one is the oars that Luffy
fought on through the bark we know that
regular Giants have crazy long life
spans after all Dodie and bragi were
just casually dueling for one 100 years
Ancient Giants who are multiple times
taller than regular Giants could have an
even longer lifespan as well also with
the ice preserving horses tissue the
dating here could just be plain wrong
making his death look a lot more recent
than it actually was however let's just
say that oars actually lived around 500
years ago the time that the Explorer
Nolan lived in one piece as well and
Maria just knows that it could also have
been one of orc's ancestors ore's Jr is
ORS the third that means there was an
oars II the giant skull and onigashima
has a good chance to be related to ores
as well so this could make moria's ores
ORS II and this one the giant one Awards
the first and therefore Joy boy we'll
get into more detail about that in just
a second here because I want to stick
with the Frozen and Ice thingy for a
little longer here because it is one of
the main themes that unites all Ancient
Giants in the story now when Moria dug
up oars he was frozen in ice and then
Frozen again later on through La bar but
this is far from the only Frozen giant
that we've seen in the series in Punk
Hazard there were a bunch of Frozen
preserved Giants the yeti cool Brothers
Here were some Icy Giants also on Punk
hazards the man who froze half of punk
Hazard aokiji throws one of our favorite
Giants on alhara Jaguar D Saul and he
also throws the New Joy boy Luffy and of
course in the giant freezer in marijua
emu keeps a giant Frozen Straw Hat one
that just happens to be appropriately or
sized and the straw Hat by the way is
the second thing that Ancient Giants
just seem to share throughout the story
next to the giant one in marijua you
have the yeti cool brothers wearing
actual straw hats just like Luffy salt
wore a hats or his Junior got a straw
hat from Ace and as we know Warriors ORS
was looking for his Straw Hat as well
now these are all facts in the story
that we've already seen but this is just
the first of five layers that I've
discovered because this Theory goes much
much deeper and the last level is a
theory so insane that if true would
change one piece forever as we know it
so let's go on deeper and look at the
core of this Theory are there actual
signs or even better some evidence that
oars was joyboy Luffy's predecessor well
let's start simply from a pal
perspective where ore seems to
definitely qualify for the role of
joyboy I probably remember that Modia
once challenged and got defeated by
kaido in wano that was when he was still
a rookie it's also when he took ryuma's
body to turn him into a zombie as well
and when the straw hats arrive in
through labarric Moria had still not
given up on becoming pirate king and
challenging the yonko so he thought that
with orsus zombie even if not with the
same full strength of the original he
could defeat kaido this time I mean
Moria has the bodies of people like Yuma
and Captain John one of the former rocks
Pirates and still his Masterpiece to
becoming pirate king was worse he
clearly knew exactly whom he had pulled
out of the ice there and so apparently
did the government now Zoro sacrificed
for Luffy and the crew as well as the
battle at marineford were two such
incredibly epic moments that Ichiro Ora
got to sneak in a very important detail
pretty much unnoticed the Government
tried to assassinate morya not just once
but twice after they found out that he
had recovered oars first they sent Kuma
to do it and then during the war at
Marine Ford someone and quote unquote
above the Marines or the doflamingo to
take Moria out as well and there are
really not that many people that could
do that it was either emu himself or the
gorosei an order from the highest level
the five elders and emu of course know
about Joy boy and the void Century
they've worked hard to eradicate any
evidence from his existence or his
powers from history I mean just remember
how hard they tried to hunt and
discredit joyboy's Nikka fruit that was
ultimately stolen by Shanks and then
eaten by Luffy and meanwhile the
government themselves also wanted to
create an Army of Ancient Giants as law
explains to us it would be their
ultimate and unbeatable weapon the same
is true for big mom and kaido both of
whom most likely know about Joy boy just
remember the giant kids from Punk Hazard
as well as the numbers I mean kaido who
himself has strong Oni features believed
himself to be Joy boy for a while before
he then started looking for someone else
who could possibly fill that role
Blackbeard and rocks two people who most
likely also know more about the true
history than most others might know
about orsa's significance too
Blackbeard's Jolly Roger are three
skulls and those three skulls can also
be found on both oars and ORS Jr's belts
meanwhile Roxas Jolly Roger is a skull
with horns now this could be a
coincidence and maybe it means something
completely different we really don't
know yet what we do know is that ORS was
actively painted as evil he is described
as the crew cool giant called the
continent polar that's because Legend
has it that he amassed countries and
Islands under his control with his band
of villains now it's very plausible that
ORS was a terrible monster that's a real
possibility but there's also a decent
chance that things might not just be
what they seem here because we do know
that the world government is pretty much
the Marie condo of changing people's
history and true nature does this person
Inspire Love and Hope in you defame them
call them a devil get creative and
extinguish the spark of joy for anyone
who tries to rise up against you so ORS
being called a devil goes very well with
what we know from Nico Robin and the
devil as you know is the enemy of gods
now there is a whole lot of symbolism
surrounding the Giants and the devil
that I just won't get into too much here
they're solid Biblical name devil fruits
Adam and Eve tree you get it the point
is devils in one piece are the good guys
as for the continent pulling well this
has hasn't been officially confirmed but
it seems pretty clear that wano is the
result of just that continent being
pulled together it's a mix of different
islands with different climates pulled
together possibly so that different
people and races from all across the
world could live there in peace and
safety together if you remember Toki who
traveled into this time period from the
void Century itself and who is part of
the wano Clans and culture did not
actually know where wanna was and was
looking for it and so the simple
explanation here could be that wano as a
place simply didn't exist yet maybe Joy
boy told her of his plans to create the
island wano and told her to go look for
it now this of course goes hand in hand
perfectly with the gargantuan skull
located right in front of wano it's
possibly ors's ancestor who died after
pulling the islands together we do know
that zunisha was joyboy's companion
which would make a lot of sense
size-wise here and don't forget that
zunisha heard joyboy's return as Luffy
awakened his fruit on top of the
gigantic skull the same skull that kaido
who was obsessed his entire life with
joyboy's return made his headquarters on
now really we have gotten no
confirmation yet if that giant creature
here was actually alive at some point
nor who it really was so this could all
just be a bit of a red herring that odas
throwing at us but let's go another
level deep according to most theories
the main piece of evidence for one
version of Oris being Joy boy is ORS
supposed parallels and connections with
Luffy during Thriller bark and I mean
most obviously first of all he gets
Luffy's Shadow just like Luffy is the
second coming of Joy boy Luffy and ORS
have a direct link now and ores does
behave exactly like Luffy however isn't
that explained pretty much by Luffy's
Shadow being inside him after all the
zombies do all take on parts of the
personality from the shadow that they're
infused with or they could be an expo
elimination for that you see other
Shadow zombies seem to be in Conflict a
little bit between the shadow
personality and the body's original
personality for example ryuma's original
personality and Brook's Shadow seemed to
be vying for control here and there and
there seems to be a bit of a mismatch
between the two however ORS is
immediately acting just like Luffy and
there is never another sign of any other
personality besides that really now we
could see that as him simply adopting
Luffy's personality but it could also be
that Luffy and the original auris were
more alike than we would initially
expect them to be for example we do see
ORS attempting to put on a straw hat now
he doesn't find a giant straw hat but he
does make do temporarily with a piece of
a building now again this could just be
interpreted as Luffy's strong
personality looking for his signature
treasure straw hat but we've seen a
giant Straw Hat beneath marijua that
would be a perfect fit for this
particular ancient Giants what I
personally find much more peculiar is
when ORS attempts to use gomogomo
techniques the zombie body actually
stretches now the reasoning we get for
this within the arc is that the body is
just following the shadow but is that
actually what's happening I mean what if
horse's body already had rubber
properties because he already had
Luffy's devil fruit while he was alive
of course this is something we can only
speculate on for right now we don't have
any other example of a zombie with a
devil fruit besides Brooks and that one
isn't exactly applicable because of its
special use in addition we haven't been
able to see whether the body of a devil
fruit user maintains properties of its
devil fruit for example wood Luffy's
bodies stay rubbery after death or would
it just revert back to normal once the
fruit is reincarnated now I do think
that ORS being already stretchy is much
less of a stretch than suddenly gaining
devil fruit abilities through moria's
powers and kind of Luffy's Shadow
influencing the corpse to that crazy
degree I mean otherwise Moria has one of
the most powerful fruits of all time
being basically able to clone abilities
from the people he steals the Shadows
from also I mean speaking of stretches
right now this is a real reach but if
you look at the swirl patch on ors's
belly it kind of resembles the pattern
of the gomugomonomi but I mean that's
just really random probably means
nothing and while we're at it right now
let me throw in another few random
pieces of evidence here like Oda making
meat or his favorite food or that or
says that Luffy is his enemy and
introduces himself when Sanji addresses
him as Luffy so Oris is clearly aware of
who he is just like ryuma and on the
cover for volume 48 we see Oris and
Luffy in the same pose with Oris teeth
giving Luffy horns now could this be
more evidence for the theory I mean I
guess it makes sense if you want to look
at it that way but these could all also
be explained differently or simply be
coincidences so let's be critical here
and give Moria the benefit of the doubts
maybe he really has the most ridiculous
devil fruit in the world maybe ORS is
simply so much like Luffy because
Luffy's Shadow is just that powerful and
honestly I personally don't even think
that this horse was Joy boy at all I
mean it could well have been
foreshadowing for a version of Oris
being Joy boy because the gargantuan
skull onigashima is still my personal
favorite candidate here if anything
Thriller bark might have been more of a
giant hint for the real Joy boy and what
he was like which was most likely a
whole lot like Luffy now Luffy is
already confirmed to be joyboy and we've
already seen Luffy turn into a giant at
more than one occasion we have a number
of different versions of gear third but
in particular his giant form during his
Awakening that allowed him to beat kaido
that fist right there was the size of
onigashima which would have been the
right size of the creature whose skull
we see here and since Modia was
convinced that Oris could defeat kaido
well maybe he was right about that and
foreshadowed this exact moment because
interestingly enough it's the exact same
giant fist that makes kaido recognize
Luffy as Joy boy before while he's
completely obliterated really so let's
just say we push aside ores on Thriller
Barrack for a second here as a candidate
for Joey Boy and focus on this who were
these Giga giants like the skull on
onigashima or this one on Punk Hazard
and where did they go you know it's a
time to go down another level this is
where things get super spicy but first
if you've enjoyed this video so far and
made it to the final level well
congratulations and please make sure to
subscribe for more content I have a ton
of awesome stuff just like this coming
up now ORS and ORS Jr are already the
largest Giants in one piece but they
dwarf in comparison with these two
skulls the numbers who are failed
attempts to make Ancient Giants easily
fit inside the giant skull Dome to party
there but as We Know know these
creatures aren't the only enormous
things in the one piece world you have
giant elephants sea Kings goldfish trees
Gates and even the Tower of imple down
reaches from the bottom of the ocean
which we know to be 10 kilometers deep
all the way to the surface so for
comparison the largest building on earth
right now is the Burj Khalif and it's
quote unquote only
828 meters tall in other words imple
down is 12 times taller than the tallest
building Humanity has ever built and
even if it's only half that size that's
still very impressive but clearly the
giant things from the past have gotten
smaller and smaller over time Ancient
Giants are getting smaller and smaller
with each generation as are normal
Giants and maybe even humans now this
phenomenon actually exists in our world
as well as we now know there were actual
Hobbit people and small elephants that
evolved due to something called Island
dwarfism it's basically an evolutionary
process that reduces body size is when a
large animal is limited to a small
environment primarily Islands which
whoopty do look at that is just what we
have in one piece could it be that the
one piece World once had much much more
land for these giant creatures and
structures to evolve I mean the one
piece world does look incredibly
artificial after all and we've just
gotten confirmation from the manga that
one piece takes place in a
post-apocalyptical world that used to
have advanced technology there is Pangea
Castle on top of the red line the only
continent in the world and Pangea as you
know was the name of the super continent
that once existed here on Earth Andy by
now Infamous globe on O'Hara with
multiple moons also shows something that
could very well be the red line but with
many larger land masses butted up
against it that clearly don't exist
anymore so could the mythology loving
Oda have been inspired by the flat myth
that exists in pretty much every culture
in our world as well or in other words
was the world of one piece at some point
flooded until only islands remained well
there might be some hints for that most
obvious of all is of course the literal
Arc Noah an ancient ship large enough to
carry an entire civilization and based
on the ship that was kind of connected
to the entire flood myth you have
curious underwater structures all
throughout one piece the giant whirlpool
and the Holland and his Lobby placed
directly next to these enormous Gates
larger than anything else in one piece
that also reached down all the way to
the bottom of the ocean next to it imple
down a tower that looks like a defense
tower with places to stand outside and
potentially harboring a whole nation of
under attack from a major enemy a
structure that is also built from bottom
to top not the other way around places
like arubana in Alabaster are curiously
placed on top of this tall plateau and
in wano we've already seen an entire
ancient world sunken underneath the
water but what on Earth could do
something like this well now that we
know about the futuristic technology
that used to exist in one piece before
the void Century it's really not that
hard to imagine really the ancient
kingdom was probably even more
technologically advanced than Humanity
in our own world right now with giant
robots and frequent space travel so I
mean if we have the potential to destroy
our planets they surely had that ability
as well right in one piece Uranus named
after the Greek god of the sky is said
to possess Powers enough to destroy
whole worlds not Islands worlds and this
is stated as a matter of fact in one
piece even by people as scientifically
accurate as Robin so how do people know
what Uranus is actually capable of well
because its powers might have been
witnessed before it might well be that
the ancient weapon Uranus has been used
not only once but even twice before
history repeating itself for all we know
there's not only the void Century in one
piece but a whole pre-pre-history before
it places like arubana date back 4 000
years ago the atom tree five thousand
years ago this is all way before the
ancient Kingdom this could well have
been the age where people like the sun
god nikolift though this is truly
speculation now so let's put it aside
matter of fact is that there are signs
throughout the world of one piece that a
cataclysmic flood occurred at least once
that created this world of islands with
the rulers or Gods as they're known of
the worlds whether it's the lunarians or
the celestial dragons living on top of
the red line far Out Of Reach but we're
not quite done yet let's go down to that
final crazy level that brings this all
the way back to ORS yes I haven't
forgotten what this video was all about
originally now since we're already kind
of in the land of speculation now let me
start with the premise here what if
Uranus was not a weapon used by the
ancient Kingdom as is commonly assumed
for some reason but against it let me
should use the Titan myth the person who
came up with this really deserves a
medal of Swords by the way now in case
you're not super familiar with Greek
mythology the Gods like Zeus pluton
Poseidon and Uranus were not the first
to rule the world it was actually the
Titans after defeating the Titans the
gods then banished them to Tartarus to
hell and build their Castle on Mount
Olympus now this would very nicely
combine both the abrahamic influences of
the floods the Adam and Eve tree and the
devil fruit with the Greek creation myth
at the same time in case you're
wondering Tartarus and Hades are not the
same thing by the way Hades is where
people go when they die but Tartarus
according to Zeus is as far beneath
Hades as Heaven is above Earth and we do
know that the red line goes just as high
above the ocean as it goes beneath it
also I want to know that not all Titans
in these myths were actually tight in
size some were human size and of course
the Titans are known as the natural
enemies of of the Gods now doesn't this
all fit in very very nicely with all of
One Piece surrounding the three gates of
Justice bigger than anything else in the
story that could represent the Locking
away of the Titans we have the island of
justice and his Lobby the island of
punishment imple down and the island of
death Marine headquarters and all three
together form the image of hell and
aslabi has the three-headed Cerberus
image through the three-headed Guardian
Baskerville imple down is modeled after
Dante's Inferno even including Fiddler's
Green as nukama islands and war is
considered to be the best representation
of Hell on Earth which we do experience
in Marine Ford which was Luffy's
personal hell so could the three gates
of justice and the giant whirlpool be
the thing that trapped the Titans the
only race at the bottom of the ocean
which would of course also fit very well
with the idea of Love tale being down
there too does Luffy's Journey like so
many other Heroes take him over the edge
of the world to the Bottom of the Sea to
free the only race so that the Titans
the original inhabitants of the one
piece world can walk the planet once
again this would of course also fit in
perfectly with the reveal of the ancient
Kingdom's advanced technology the Titans
just like Oris AKA joyboy would have
been the inhabitants of this great
Kingdom and by the way if you're curious
about that big reveal and what it means
I broke it down for you in this video
right here so you can go watch that next
if you like